we got to keep this thing moving because
George Foreman is hungry one of
tonight's foreign language film nominees
is from Norway it's called the other
side of Sunday or as we'd like to call
it here Monday
she's from was sort of easy wasn't it
she she's from The English Patient and
he's from the Johnson administration let
me take that again let me roll up
everything woody I everybody every
element was easy wasn't it
she's from the English Patient and he's
from the Johnson administration it's a
website joke please welcome Academy
Award nominee Kristin Scott Thomas and
president of the Motion Picture
Association of America Jack Valenti
we have the pleasure of bestowing the
Oscar for Best Picture in a foreign
language to one of five nominees to
millions of people around the world
Kristen we're speaking a foreign
language right now and I might add
you speak it elegantly thank you but the
universal tongue is the language of
movies and now to the business at hand
the nominees for best foreign language
film are from Georgia a chef in love
Nana georgette C director
from the Czech Republic kaalia young
spheric director
from Norway the other side of Sunday
ferret less time director from Russia
prisoner of the mountains Sergei Bodrov
director
from France edicue
Patrice LeConte director
and the Oscar goes to the Czech Republic
for Kuya
thank you dear Oscar I was not able to
sleep because of you last night and I
was all night long I was wondering where
you are going to end up tonight and you
are going to Prague you don't know where
it is it's in Europe and this is this is
your new family this is my Papa who
wrote a script
this is producer Eric Abraham and this
is Kolya
we we promise you that our next films
will not make ashamed you and maybe one
day we will make a brother for you
thank you thanks to everyone at home and
here thank you